and i i just think the data engine side
of that so getting the data to learn all
the concepts that you're saying now is
an incredible process it's this
iterative process of just
it's this this hydrogen at many
we're changing the name to something
else okay all right i'm sure it would be
equally as
rick and morty like there's a lot of
yeah we've re-architected the neural net
uh
neural nets in the cars so many times
it's crazy
oh so every time there's a new major
version you'll rename it to something
more ridiculous or
uh or memorable and beautiful sorry not
ridiculous of course
if you see the full the full like uh
array of neural nets that that that are
operating in the car it kind of boggles
the mind there's so
there's so many layers it's crazy um
so
yeah
um but
and and we
we started off with
uh
simple neural nets that were uh
basically
image recognition on a single frame
from a single camera
and then
uh trying to knit those together with
it you know it with the
c
i should say we
we're really primarily running c here
because c plus plus is
too much overhead and we have our own c
compiler
so to get maximum performance we
actually wrote rotor and c compiler and
are continuing to optimize rc compiler
uh for
maximum efficiency in fact we've just
recently
uh done a new rov on a c compiler that
will compile directly to our autopilot
hardware so you want to compile the
whole thing down and with your own
compiler yeah like so efficiency here
because there's all kinds of computers
cpu gpu there's like basic types of
things
and you have to somehow figure out the
scheduling across all of those things
and so you're compiling the code down
yeah it does all okay
this is so that's why there's a lot of
people involved
because there's a lot of hardcore uh
software engineering at a very sort of
bare metal level uh because you we're
trying to do a lot of compute
that's constrained to
the
you know our full self-driving computer
so and we want to try to have the
highest frames per second
possible
um
with been a sort of very finite amount
of compute
and power so
um
we really put a lot of effort into the
efficiency of our compute
and and so there's actually a lot of
work done by
some very talented software engineers at
tesla that
uh at a very foundational level to
improve the efficiency of compute and
how we use the
the trip accelerators uh which are
basically um
dot you know uh doing matrix math dot
products uh like a brazilian dot
products
and it's like what what what are neural
nets it's like
computer-wise like 99
dot products
so
you know um and you want to achieve as
many
high frame rates like a video game you
want
yeah full resolution
high frame rate high frame rate low
latency
um
low jitter uh so
i think one of the things for um moving
towards now is no post-processing of the
image through the um
uh
the image signal processor so
um
like for what happens for cameras is
that almost all cameras is they
um
there's a lot of post processing done in
order to make pictures look pretty
and so we don't care about pictures
looking pretty um
we just want the data we so we're
removing just raw photon counts
so the system will
like the
image that
that the computer sees is actually much
more than what
you see if you're represented on a
camera it's got much more data
and even in very low light conditions
you can see that there's a small photon
count difference between
you know
this spot here and that spot there which
means that so it can see in the dark
incredibly well
um because it can detect these tiny
differences in photon counts
like much better than you'd
possibly imagine
um so
and and then we also save
uh 13 milliseconds on a latency uh
so
um from removing the post processing on
the image yes yeah it's like um
because we've got you know eight cameras
and and then there's uh
roughly i don't know one and a half
milliseconds or so
maybe 1.6 milliseconds of latency um
for each camera and so
like
going to just
uh
basically bypassing the image processor
uh gets us back 13 milliseconds of
latency which is important
um
and we track latency all the way from
you know photon hits the
the camera to
you know all the steps that it's got to
go through to get you know go through
the
um
the various neural nets and the the c
code and
there's a little bit of c plus plus
there as well um
well i can maybe a lot but it the core
stuff is the heavy duty computers will
nc um
and uh
and so so we track that latency all the
way to an output command to the um
drive unit to accelerate uh the brakes
just to
slow down the steering here turn left or
right um
so because you've got to output a
command that's going to go to controller
and like some of these controllers have
an update frequency that's maybe uh 10
hertz or something like that which is
slow that's like now you lose 100
milliseconds potentially
so um so then we want to update the
the drivers on the
like steering and braking control to
have um
more like a 100 hertz instead of 10
hertz then you could have 10
milliseconds latency instead of 100
milliseconds worst case latency and
actually jitter is more of a challenge
than than latency because latency is
like you can you can you can anticipate
and predict but if you're but if you've
got a stack up of things going from the
camera to the to the computer
through then a series of other computers
and finally to an actuator on the car if
you have a stack up of
uh
of tolerances of timing tolerances then
you can have quite a variable latency
which is called jetter
and and that makes it
a hard to to to anticipate exactly what
how you should turn the car or
accelerate because you know if you got
maybe
150 200 milliseconds of jitter then you
could be off by you know after 0.2
seconds and this can make this could
make a big difference uh so you have to
interpolate somehow to to
to uh deal with the effects of jitter so
you that you can make like
robust controlled decisions
yeah then you have to uh so the jitters
and the sensor information
or the jitter can occur at any stage in
the pipeline you can if you have just if
you have a fixed latency you can
anticipate um
and and
like say okay we know that
our information is for argument's sake
150 milliseconds stale
like so for um 140 400 150 milliseconds
from
photon second camera to
um
where you can measure a change in the
acceleration of the vehicle
um
so
then uh then you can say okay well we're
gonna
until we know it's 150 milliseconds so
we're going to take that into account
and uh
and compensate for that latency however
if you've got then 150 milliseconds of
latency plus 100 milliseconds of jitter
that's which could be anywhere from zero
zero to 100 milliseconds on top so then
your latency could be from 150 to 50
milliseconds now you got 100
milliseconds that you don't know what to
do with and again that's basically
random
so getting rid of jitter is extremely
important
and that affects your control decisions
and all those kinds of things
okay
um yeah the car is just going to
fundamentally maneuver better with lower
jitter um
the cars will maneuver with superhuman
ability and reaction time much faster
than a human
i mean i think over time the
autopilot full self driving will be
capable of maneuvers that um
you know
uh
you know are far more than what like
james bond could do in like the best
movie type of thing that's exactly what
i was imagining in my mind as you said
it's like an impossible maneuver that a
human couldn't do you know
you